[Music]
Modern Family that show such a funny
show and you get the impression watching
it that you guys are very close-knit as
a cast like you really are and friends
and I get that sense also because you
you tweet out these pictures of your
cast mate Sofia Vergara's but her but
yes whenever you get a chance well you
know what I am looking out for America
yeah you know and when I'm on the set
and she happens to be wearing a juicy
pair of hot pants I'm like I shouldn't
be the only person that gets to see this
I should let the world see this so I
tweeted out a picture the other day that
just with the caption work with Sophia's
rear end and Jesse Tyler Ferguson Scotch
do you have them I think we have it yeah
you sent this out this is a picture you
took that's right the news organizations
pick it up because Sophia retweeted it
and wrote you know Eric you know with a
angry face on there so everybody thought
oh my gosh modern family rift they wrote
articles about there's now a rift
between Sophia and Eric she's not happy
about this little do they know that was
like the seventh take we took of her but
to get it exactly the way she wants it
yes right now good let me do it again
you always arch the back for the ass you
know so she gets these your good
pointers they are they really are just
right but I think Conan the best thing
about that is it's nobody not one person
picked up on the fact that Jesse Tyler
Ferguson crotch is also in that picture
and I think the true victim here is
Jesse Tyler Ferguson 's crotch area
because it's completely upstaged by
Sofia's but yeah well so his whole body
language in that picture is what are you
gonna do there's no winning that makes
me laugh that people think she's mad at
the mad at that right now I know that
you're a huge huge Dodgers fan yes I am
and in fact I saw you at I went to my
first Dodgers game in years I went to a
Dodgers game during the playoffs and you
were there we were sitting near each
other yeah and Conan I saw you totally
check out Larry King's ass you sent me
to check out Larry King's Larry King let
me tell you guys Larry King was in the
same aisle as you do you agree yes Jerry
King showed up I'm building my case yeah
so Conan gets up and his guests get up
to let Larry King yet Larry King in and
I look over in Conan's just like staring
at Larry King's rear end and this is I
agree with that too so I don't have to
build a case here at all you have to put
the case it's in wonderment
have you seen no I mean it's amazing I
guess I have but I never knowed it I got
a picture of it no I'm just kidding I
wish
yeah Larry's like another one you gotta
arch the back
that's it baby but I was looking because
it's I couldn't see an ass that's why
it's like you put jeans on a high school
labs going yeah I'm sorry that's what it
is Mary King looks like a frog walking
around on his hind legs he's got like a
littles little butt and then these
really skinny legs it's adorable but
anyway I look over at you and I just
gave you the not for the hat all right
all right
I'm glad well I did I was not prepared
for you to agree with it that this is a
real man this is a true transparent man
right here I'm comfortable in my
sexuality I'm being cheered for staring
at larry king's play but honestly if you
get a chance and you will you will